the only thing wrong with the teen
idol thing is that people
label you and they and they stick you in
a spot and they won't let you out of it
and uh
i would feel very ripped off
if that would happen to me if i was just
stuck in that mold and i couldn't get
out of it
uh because to me
the important thing is doing the work
the important thing is is to uh
to act
and to do the best job i can
the least important thing to me is
uh
becoming famous and being well known and
you know trying to be everybody's hero
that's not what i'm about
i would just like to do the best work i
can possibly do
and be accepted for doing that as
opposed to just being accepted for uh
somebody who's
who kind of looks okay and is uh
you know
whatever you know yeah on some hit show
or whatever the hell it is you know i do
miss privacy it's a little strange
it's a little strange to go out to a
restaurant or something
and have people sort of you know
gawking at you like like you're some
sort of
i don't know like an animal on display
or some sort of you know freak it's a
little strange
to get used to
i don't know if if things continue to
happen for me and
hopefully they will
hopefully i'll get used to it you know
people have said that to me they said
you know now that you're in this
position you gotta
you know watch what you do i guess huh
but
i don't really
i don't really want to do that because
if i do that then i'm being dishonest to
myself and besides being dishonest to
myself i'm being dishonest to the people
who are watching
you know i'm going to do what i do and
hopefully people can accept that
like i said i'm not out to prove that
i'm
the messiah or something
there's a weird thing you know people
work their whole lives and they say oh
i'm gonna do everything everything i can
to be famous and then when once you get
famous
you do everything you can so you can
stay out of the public eye
so there's there's a line in there
somewhere that i think everybody's sort
of missed
i think i missed it
[Music]